Ooh these bells were
already a bad idea
audio-wise thats gonna be real bad!
If anyone ever uses that phrase "Oh
I'll be there with bells on" to say that they're like
excited to show up for something, tell them to
f**k directly off.
This is the look today. Let's all take a collective
inhale, *inhales*
*exhales* exhale, and get over it.
Uh-oh, she's a sass factory
today. Hi guys my name is Grace Helbig if
you did not know, now you know your life is different now.
It's Friday, we made it, TGIF.
Do you feel things?
Me too. I went on
twitter, and I asked you guys what kind of
video you wanted to see today. A lot of you said some
sort of like, diy
Christmas, Christmas sweater decoration
type of thing and then other people said stream of
consciousness video, so I'm
combining both of them. I'm diy-ing
an ugly Christmas sweater while
streaming consciousness at you.
Are you ready for this?
*sings 'are you ready for this'*
I like that song
because it, asks a question
but has no interest in your
answer. That's like what I do
here. So ugly Christmas sweaters are a
thing. How? Why?
There are bigger questions, that I
should be asking how and why to
than ugly Christmas sweaters.
Ugly Christmas sweaters are a thing!
I accept that. I've never diy-ed an
ugly Christmas sweater before but
it seems fairly straight forward. What you need
is; a sweater and you need a bunch
of s**t to decorate it with, and the
rest is up to you. So I'm gonna try and diy
the ugliest Christmas sweater I can
imagine. While at the same time
consciously streaming thoughts at
you. God, I don't think I can do two
things at once. Sometimes I breathe and walk. I lied.
Phew, okay. Why is this sweater all
static-y? I didn't know sweater could get
static. What? Okay.
Great, what am I doing? Why am I touching this
sweater like it's pizza dough? Just
lay out your f**king sweater and start decorating.
I'm gonna use a hot glue gun *evil hehe*
How are you guys? How is your world? How is your
life? How are things and how are stuff?
See that was me doing my impression of that
song; y'all ready for this?
I don't care, to know your
answer.
I do.
*nervous sound*
Yeah I'm
adding bells because I'm... dumbass.
What's happening in the world? This is where now we
look up stuff that's happening in the world. Prince Harry and
Rihanna get HIV tests together in
Barbados
I know that there's a
bigger reason that they did that but
I don't want to know,
I just want to live
with that headline for a second. Into it.
I made myself steak and potatoes last night
cause I've run out of things to do
that make me seem interesting. The steak
was not good, and the potatoes were very
mediocre. If not below
average and that has been thrilling life updates
with Grace Helbig. Thank you for your participation.
Are you guys doing anything exciting for
the holidays? *horse noise*
Why was that said in such a sad tone self?
I don't know, self.
We need to stop this conversation with ourselves.
We have company. How was your
thanksgiving? Only people from the
United States. I'm going through a
real Melissa Etheridge moment right now.
That's it, no follow up questions.
*laugh* Oh I did not ration
these bells appropriately. What's your favourite
holiday song? Mines
Oh Come All Ye Faithful, cause that's
sexual as f**k. Which toe do you prefer
mistle or camel? AH! AH! OW!
I GLUED THE BELL TO MY FINGER! OW I GLUED IT TO MY FINGER!
Aahh mother
f****r! Oww. I
just, ow!
Man, sports! Right guys?
Can you believe it's December already? That was my impression of a conversation
you don't wanna be part of. I used all my
bells, do I have any more bells so here's the
bad news, I'm out of bells. We can make this work.
This is like a fun activity to do with
um, like your friends
or just like people you don't trust
to be fun to hang out with without an
activity involved. What do you guys want for Christmas?
So I realised today  I haven't drank
water in like two weeks!
Guys so far this is looking great! It's
kinda s**tty. Ugly Christmas sweaters, are like
Liam Neeson, like you just can't
f**k 'em up. Why does it smell like farts ijn
here, and I know that I did not
fart. You can't tell
but I am shaming my dog
with my eyes right now. The moon's been
pretty cool lately. *laughs*
That's my impression of someone that's just,
out of conversation topics on the
first date. I'll use puffy paint!
Cause I have puffy paint, because I,
am a domestic, desperate
goddess. Oooh! Okay. Wait.
Let's do one thing at a time puffy paint first, and then we're gonna look up
what national holidays it
is, cause that's my favourite thing
to look up with you guys. Anyone do anything
really embarrassing lately?
Good talk y'all. While our puffy
paint dries a bit, I
am going, to look up what
national holidays, it is.
*silence* I don't
like my sweater. Ooh, this weekend,
the third, national roof over your
head day! That makes me wanna p-raise the
roof!
I
vehemently hate myself. Ohhhh
s**t! Get your plans
ready for Monday, cause Monday,
is bathtub party day!
Whhaaaat? I'm gonna go to the other
holiday website just to confirm these holidays.
Okay, Saturday the third, roof over your
head day! It's confirmed. And Monday
is confirmed, it is bathtub
party day. *laughs* Well get
ready for Monday's video, because
we're having a bathtub party!
Send me your suggestions, in the comments
of how we can celebrate bath
tub party day. It's BPD
baby! Well, this has been it for
the stream of consciousness. Sorry, the stream
is a little dry today, but
my ugly Christmas sweater is
done and I wanna show it off to you
guys. Ta-Da! *jingle bells*
If this isn't the ugliest Christmas sweater you've
ever seen, I don't
know what you've seen. Happy Holiday's everybody!
If you make an ugly Christmas sweater,
tweet me, a photo of it!
I'd be curious to see how ugly
your Christmas sweaters can get! Thank you guys
for watching this video. If you liked it at all give it a thumbs up.
Leave a comment down below on what we should
do to celebrate bathtub party day on
Monday and hit this button right
here to subscribe to this youtube channel because
art like this doesn't happen every-
day.
And I've never made myself an ugly Christmas
sweater that I can recall,
though, I forget every-
thing I do in life
immediately when it's over. Thank
god, I have a
library of narcissism,
to go back
and watch! *laughs nervously*
*inhale*